it's called the mckinney fire it started
on friday grew from 1 to 160 square
kilometers in 24 hours and is now
covering well over 200 square kilometers
and continuing to spread
a mandatory evacuation order was issued
an estimated two thousand people left
their home saturday and another five
hundred have been evacuated in the
course of sunday
many leaving behind their possessions
like this 81 year old my house is gone
all my furniture all my clothes shoes
coats boots
everything's gone
some decided to leave before the
mandatory evacuation and managed to save
some of their belongings
yeah we got out before the fires
actually they gave us a red flag to get
out because we don't want to be there to
when they do say get out have 15 minutes
to get out and then we got all our shows
packed up ready to go so we get out of
there as soon as possible the swirling
winds made the course of the fire
impossible to predict yeah i mean it
could come from any angle at this point
it's just a matter of where the winds
take it
over 60 hikers who are on the popular
pacific crest trail were safely rescued
they had about 20 feet of visibility on
the trail at the time that they you know
chose to call in and try to get some
help
the mckinney fire is by far the largest
but across the west of the united states
more fires are flaring up
erratic weather is threatening to bring
dry thunderstorms with dangerous
lightning but little to no actual rain
and above all the soaring heat is
creating the ideal conditions for fires
to start and spread
mike hannah al jazeera